a Bill Gates Venture aims to spray dust
into the atmosphere to block the Sun
what could go wrong Yep this is a Mr
Burns and this was but this was supposed
to burn this was supposed to go forward
as an official test a couple months ago
it was postponed but the test is still
going to be going forward with Bill
Gates literally blocking out the sun
because of a climate I pictured Bill
Gates literally a 100 million miles wide
blocking up the sun when you said that
no no he's got a remote and when he
presses it a gigantic metal disc goes up
we just don't he's just you know he's
just an unaccountable billionaire and
businessman that buys off the corporate
media there's nothing to worry about
here it's not like he believes there's
too many people in this world oh wait oh
yeah this is the kind of sun burns
easily and that's really what it's about
he's like a pasty white dude and he's
like I don't know why I don't buy lotion
he does wear a lot of sweaters he's like
say yes you know maybe he's you know it
gets like eczema or something more
magnesium Bill get more green vegetables
that's how you avoid sunburn
yeah I mean I don't think the dude's
eating vegetables I think he's just he
wants to block out the sun I'm thinking
yeah that sounds so villainous yes I
know yes what do you think I've been
screaming about this person for the last
10 years 10 years I've been like hey you
guys should look out at this guy hey hey
this guy's doing this he's doing this
he's doing this he's doing this he's
also trying to create microchips that
are going to be artificially birth
control inside inside of human beings
that that's all concerning stuff that we
should be talking about especially since
we got here talking about the new kind
of weapons that will be used during
World War III because there's also a big
potential hypothetically to say that
this war is already going on and a lot
of people don't even realize it anymore
and that right now people are dying
people are casualties of this war from
circumstances and things that they don't
see that they might be participating in
and consuming themselves for sure
viruses you can't see them that's a
great War tactic food if you poison food
or make food that is poison that's a
kind of a war tactic but it's just like
a subtle war no one wants to be the
aggressor in that war they don't want to
be found out as an aggressor you'll lose
public support so you always want the
other side to be the aggressor
you know would be really funny if like
world war three is just like the US is
bombing itself and blaming Russia and
Russia's bombing itself and blaming the
us but that's all it is and they have a
secret deal an arrangement being like
hey guys we're gonna Wag the Dog here
we're gonna stage something but we're
gonna work on this together so we could
feed the military industrial complex but
we're just gonna play pretend here well
I mean like hypothetically the uh I
think it would be funnier in the
scenario if the U.S there's no direct
conflict it's them attacking themselves
but we were a bomb today and it must
have been Russia but it was like the CIA
it's false flag after false right
nothing but false Flags Russia is like
so so I mean think about what happened
right now you've got this story where
Russia apparently is going to blow up a
dam
and there's and so Russia says Ukraine
is going to blow up a dam so Western
media says that's a signal that Russia
is going to blow the dam up to blame us
like this is how insane it is so like
all of a sudden the Ukrainian Dam
explodes and then the the Western media
says Russia did it it's a false flag
they're they're trying to blame us then
all of a sudden Russia blows up one of
its own dabs and goes no no this proves
that Ukraine did it because even we got
attacked and so everyone's just blowing
themselves up no you got to get public
support I guess but let's get to the
point where the robots fight each other
you know I think that's already
happening too or or you know you could
just deny Humanity energy and watch you
know civilization collapse on itself we
can watch food prices go up so it
becomes too expensive so people can't
afford it you could stop domestic energy
production and exploration just like the
new prime minister who's also a part of
the world economic Forum a Goldman Sachs
Banker just banned fracking inside of
all of the United Kingdom also the same
individual pushing for a central bank
digital currency uh which is akin to a
social credit score that his family has
also invested in heavily and working on
of course building with the world
economic Forum this is what's this guy's
name the PM of Rashi Rishi Rishi and he
within he just got in with like two days
ago yep and he's already ban fracking oh
yeah yeah the entire Globe United
Kingdom yep
yep one person and they're already
getting ready to to ration uh heating
oil for the winter and this is the same
person by the way that that just talked
about how the UK is going to be the
first place that is going to rewire
their entire Financial system in order
to be Net Zero oh this is the same guy
literally promising hey we're also going
to bring in a central bank digital
currency because it's going to be so
convenient when the government's able to
watch track and see every little thing
you do and tax you automatically without
you even having to fill out any tax
forms this is this is a new level of
orwellian 1984 New World Order Brave New
World that we are all facing today that
that a lot of people warned about saying
hey this is coming now this is a reality
it's like a a a a big do-over you know
like a big
you know Grand like Grande
reformatting that's yeah reformatting um
a gigantic New Beginning a restart right
restart is that something like that like
a reformat like a Reaper big rebirth I
was studying the the revolution you know
the American Revolution the first one
and uh I say right now because we're in
it right now it never stopped
um George Washington would go to the
Continental Congress they'd all go you
know they'd sit there and Washington
would barely ever speak he'd just listen
and he'd be wearing his full military
outfit and they're like yo this guy's
ready to roll like it was before the War
Began but everybody knew George was
ready to go and he shows up in full
military again they're like dude combat
finally when they make their decision
that they're gonna have to go to war
with England
um John Adams is like we've decided
who's going to lead the Army and John
Hancock's like he's the president of
Congress he's like here we go give it to
me boys and then uh they were like and
it's George Washington and Hancock's
like deflated he thought he was going to
be the guy and George didn't want it he
was like this is a suicide mission I
can't there's no way we can win this
yeah but he did it anyway
and thank God for the French how many
how many battles did he win
I don't I mean you cannot count Trenton
as a battle maybe but I I think other
than that I don't know if he he won a
single one other than Yorktown I mean
all he did was fight lose stay alive
Retreat keep going over and over and
over again you know obviously the French
come in at Yorktown they have Saratoga
which was a big win but he wasn't there
but you know sometimes he's sometimes
that's the winning stress you you know
so that's what you got to do makes a
good Commander Mel Gibson won a couple
he did that's right yeah yeah he trust
both his kids though right I know well
he had a bunch he died did he no he
didn't die at that no he wins in the end
that movie's so good Washington won six
victories at the Boston a Siege of
Boston Harlem Heights Trenton second the
Battle of Trenton uh Princeton and
Yorktown and he also was defeated six
times Long Island White Plains Fort
Washington brand new one in Germantown
and he had a tie two ties at White
Martian Monmouth
but yeah he basically just held the line
for the French to come win the war for
him no one can do it alone
that's the question about a Civil War in
the United States a lot of people on the
right think that uh it's a [ __ ] come on
the right has guns they have more
military
but people don't understand that
you know when I was reading about North
Carolina I was reading a bunch of uh
historic historical articles from
universities uh North Carolina Virginia
they were split they were like they
didn't want to secede from the union the
protections the union offered was too
great there were benefits they just want
to leave and it was only after 75 000
troops were called upon by Lincoln that
they were like that's way too much for
us we're not we're not going to support
that that's theoretical but it's split
if something were to happen in this
country you might be thinking like nah
there's no way the state would leave
like there's not enough States it
wouldn't split but there might be some
states that just look I'll put this away
Donald Trump wins in 2024 he's president
2025
California Oregon and Washington all say
outright we will not abide by federal
law pertaining to abortion or sex
changes for kids or schools and then
Trump says they have totally cut us off
so we're sending in the Army invoking
the Insurrection act something that
we've already discussed as possible
or let's say antifa starts rioting and
then Trump says we're going to shut down
these rights this time I'm not making
the same mistake the I'm invoking the
Insurrection act and then California
says we can't we can't do this is too
much Trump's sending troops now the
media obviously sides all with these
these Progressive States pushing the
cause of secession I mean that's you
know what we push it too is if they try
to Institute a draft for some sort of
offensive measure in Ukraine steps would
be like I am out I will not tolerate
that I don't know I don't know I think
red States but if Trump if the GOP wins
we're not going to have that if the
Republicans win the war is the war is
effectively a non-issue for us and
Ukraine is going to lose in two seconds
no world war look I'll put it very
simply if Trump wins and if we survive
to 2024 and World War III doesn't start
I don't think it will I hope not if
Trump wins
if Republican wins well I'll say this I
can't speak for the Republicans but if
Trump wins our involvement with Ukraine
is done Ukraine loses the war overnight
Russia walks in it just takes what they
want
it's better than world war three what
are you thinking is that possible
well I mean I I don't know if you saw
the story the other day where even the
you know the far left Progressive caucus
is oh yeah oh you know let's let's back
off what we're doing now then of course
you know they got yelled at so they had
to had to back off it but this is not
something that you know the majority of
conservative support even those on the
far left I mean their conscience is we
can't support this I mean this is the
political class in Washington you know
that have been there for years that you
know going back to you know World War II
really
um that is pushing this yeah was it 20
or 30 Representatives I'm not sure how
many I think it was it was it was a
significant number coming out against
the escalations in Ukraine which was
which is big news and should have been
covered more right but this is always
how it happens right where you have one
one spot it's like what was it Serbia in
World War one right was it Serbia where
everything happens from there right now
not everything is is World War II where
you have you know a dictator on the
March invading countries you know you
have conflagrations like this that that
set off things that once they once they
happen you cannot roll them back so
hopefully hopefully you know after
November this thing starts to get rolled
back because you know we're we're kind
of at this this brinksmanship
um which we've seen you know throughout
the Cold War which fortunately never
erupted into anything beyond these proxy
wars
um but you know hearing thought talks
about we're approaching nuclear
Armageddon or we could be looking at
nuclear Armageddon the fact that more
people aren't talking about that I mean
that's that's crazy to me absolutely
this is the first I heard of the
progressive uh out outcry about it yeah
who was it was it like AOC people I
don't think AOC Paul
um uh Jay Paul I think was the one that
sent the letter
um so she's a member of Congress uh and
then a day later you know they were
throwing staff under the bus and they
you know for for sending this letter
it's I mean you didn't think this
through you didn't you know either you
write it you send it you stand by it or
you don't send it but I mean within a
day it unraveled sometimes when I see
stuff like this I'm like is is there a
powerful spaceship hidden in off the
Horizon where you know like these
progressives they can't actually do
anything good the Democrats have no
choice is there some great and powerful
demonic entity or a super being or a
multi-dimensional creature that is
forcing them to be evil garbage I just I
just understand why you can't just be
like the war is wrong here's my letter I
don't care it was the Congressional uh
Progressive caucus that officially sent
the letter we should have some of these
individuals on uh with how close look
out look how look how cowardly they got
though they back down they apologize
they they all the BS they play come on
dude I bet there's a lot of behind the
scenes stuff be interesting to air that
yeah but I want to know what the hell
happened because they sent the letter
and then they had to backtrack why did
they have what pressure to de-escalate
the situation these people are
escalating masks
beat board wouldn't do that is going to
be a Ron Paul uh and cap libertarian and
freedom fighter that's going to progress
Human Society so we are going to be
equally and and promote freedom and and
and really uh be the best human beings
that we could be I I I'm optimistic
Jimmy Dore is calling him out and and
the the fake woke cult left despises it
but Jimmy's right yeah I want to know
what happened I want to know if it's
like a lobbyist group or if it's uh if
it's a corporate group or if it's an
intelligence agency that came to this
Progressive caucus and said stop it
right now who did it why I want to know
uh and I think the American people
deserve an answer because it's their
money going over there it's it's their
money escalating in the situation thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there